Ist dir was
Soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Sag euch jetzt mal was, es muss bloß erstmal laden
Auf lade
Ich hab keinen Bock mehr auf diesen krassen, geilen PC-Port
Wir spielen jetzt Battlefield 3
Ich weiß Passwort für meine Air-Account nicht mehr
So erstmal Battle-Log versuchen einzuloggen
Aha, funktioniert
So, ich sag euch jetzt mal was
So Leute, wer Bock hat Battlefield zu spielen?
Ich hab einen Battlefield 3-Server, hat der Patrick an den eingerichtet, The Game 402
Wir spielen jetzt eine Runde Battlefield 3
Ich hab jetzt keinen Bock mehr auf dieses verbackte Game von World War, von Call of Duty
Das geht mir auf den Sack, es kann doch nicht sein, dass das Game alle 5 Minuten mal abscheißt
Oder man nicht raus tappen darf oder sonst was
Also wer will
Kommt einfach auf meinen Battlefield-Server
Ich selbst kann mich grad anscheinend auch nicht einloggen
Ja, ah jetzt startet es, sehr schön
Game-Capture, Battlefield 3, Easy Life
Gut, wie viele Bildschirme hast du?
Edit, Game, Battlefield
Endlich mal ein Game, was nicht abscheißt
Battlefield 3
Enden wir mit dem Titel mal in was Aussagekräftiges
So, spielen wir eine Runde Battlefield
Go Go
Also wer will, ich poste den Link zum Server mal im Chat
Ja, Kurzsession vorbei, Game crashed, geht mir auf den Sack
Kein Bock mehr
Ich bringe jetzt dem Bot nochmal bei, dass der alle 5 Minuten wieder meinen Server spammt
Ich hoffe, dass man das auffindet
Wie kommst du zum neuen Code, das läuft grad in Beta
Also wenn wir den Server noch irgendwie voll kriegen, spielen wir jetzt noch ein paar Runden Battlefield
Okay, das Game läuft halt wenigstens auch mal
Der Witz ist halt, ne?
Draw, ne wie ging das?
Draw, FPS, ne
On, ah, fuck, list
Render
Draw, FPS, 1
Also man muss ja sagen, Battlefield 1 ist schon ein bisschen älter
Aber rein optisch sieht das mindestens mal genauso gut aus wie das neue Call of Duty
Läuft mit 144 FPS und funktioniert einfach und stürzt nicht ab
Also wir können ja mal gucken, ob wir den Server voll kriegen
Kann man die Server-Konsole aufmachen
Laut Server-Browser sind 3 Leute drauf, in-Game sind keine drauf
Keiner drauf
Was auch immer
Und außerdem hab ich mega Hunger
Hat dir die geile Computer gefallen?
Das hat mir Spaß gemacht, ja
Tatsächlich hat mir wirklich Spaß gemacht
Die Sache ist, dass der PC-Port so unter aller Sau ist, dass es einfach nicht ordentlich spielbar ist
Ich glaube mir ist noch kein Game innerhalb von einer Gaming-Session so oft abgekackt wie das neue Code
Da war Battlefield 4 bei Release ja nix dagegen
Ich hab irgendwie den Eindruck, mein Game zeigt Mist an
Da sind angeblich 4 Leute drauf
Ich habe irgendwie den Eindruck, mein Game zeigt Mist an, da sind angeblich vier Leute drauf, ne?
Fünf Leute sind drauf, aber ich sehe nichts.
But why?
Backt das?
Sogar Battle of Honor Warfighter war besser, da kann man sich jetzt zurecht streiten.
Außerdem habe ich nur bei Battle of Honor bisher gesehen, dass die Gegner durch den Boden teleportieren.
Ne, Audiobug hatte ich nicht.
Vielleicht bist du auf dem falschen Server, ne, bin ich nicht.
Ich bin auf meinem Server.
Ergebnis sind wieder vier Leute drauf, aber ich sehe nichts.
Leute, warum sehe ich euch nicht im Team?
Aber ich sehe euch in der Serverkonsole.
Habt ihr noch kein Team ausgewählt, kann das sein?
Ah, jetzt sehe ich Leute.
Ja, auf Leute, kommt ruf, was losgehen kann.
Ich spiele alleine, weil ich warte, dass Leute auf den Server kommen.
Wir haben das Game ja erst vor drei, vier Minuten angemacht.
Versuchen wir mal schon, hast du Punkbuster installiert, Morris?
Aber wobei, das wird zu sehen, da gibt es eine Fehlermeldung.
Ah.
Ich fand das neue Call of Duty wirklich nicht übel.
Also Gameplay technisch vom Waffenhändlinge hat mir das schon ganz gut gefallen.
Aber die Stabilität und die Menüs und der PC-Port, das sah einfach wieder grausam schlecht aus.
Hey, Panzer geht kaputt.
Warum?
Panzer soll nicht kaputt gehen.
Jetzt sind wir angeblich schon fünf Leute auf dem Server.
Joint aber nicht, okay, ja keine Ahnung.
Also am Server liegt es nicht.
Für mich ist Battlefield 3 übrigens immer noch ein Beispiel für ein Game mit richtig gutem Sound.
Was hältst du davon, dass man vor einigen Spielen, wenn es ums Spiel geht, etwas zu tun hat?
Ich glaube, es geht ums Spiel.
Was hältst du davon, dass bei Fortnite aus Versehen Crossplay aktiviert war?
Hab ich nix vor mitgekriegt, erzähl mal.
Ist Fortnite nicht dieses, dieses ähm...
Dieses, äh, dieser Zombie-Modus, dieses Zombie-Modus-Game, wo sie dann gesagt haben, wir machen jetzt Battle Royale rein, weil PUBG so erfolgreich ist.
Ach, PS4 kommt mit Xbox One zu, ja das ist gut.
Das finde ich gut.
Ja, Crossplay von Konsole zu Konsole ist gut.
Aber Crossplay zwischen Konsole und PC ist halt Fail.
Weil halt einfach die Leute auf der Konsole auf die Fresse kriegen, ne.
Weil man einfach nicht mit Mouse, äh, bzw. mit Controller gegen Mouse-Tastatur anstinken kann mit, äh, Aim-Technisch.
Geht halt einfach nicht.
Es gab ja mal diesen Test von Microsoft mit Halo damals, wo sie gesagt haben, wir wollen Halo Crossplay und alles machen.
Da haben sie ja mal getestet.
So die richtig krassen Halo Pros auf der Xbox gegen mittelmäßige Spieler auf dem PC, Aim-Technisch.
Und die Pros haben halt einfach nur richtig auf die Fresse gekriegt.
Einfach nur weil Mouse-Tastatur besser ist.
Was Aim anbelangt.
Kann man, kann man, muss man nicht diskutieren, ist einfach so.
Deswegen finde ich Crossplay zwischen, zwischen Konsole finde ich das super.
Also Crossplay zwischen, meinetwegen sogar Switch, Switch, PS4, Xbox.
Ich hätte dich schon, ich hätte dich schon vor 5 Minuten killen können.
Kennst du noch mein PC-Problem von vorher, dass du hast vergessen zu sagen, dass du ein Laptop hast anstatt ein Desktop-PC.
Na, ein Laptop ist immer schwierig was dran zu machen.
Na, da kommt man ja meistens gar nicht richtig ran.
So, auf geht's.
Ja, Crossplay Forza. Forza ist ja auch ein Rennspiel.
Da geht es jetzt nicht irgendwie um Aim mit Controller gegen Tastatur und mit Controller gegen Mouse.
Rennspiele würde ich sagen hat man sogar mit einem Controller ein bisschen Vorteil gegen Tastatur.
Wobei man sich dann einfach an PC-Controller anschließen kann.
Oder an ein Lenkrad oder so.
Moment mal, ich sehe den, ich sehe meinen eigenen Streben nicht mehr.
Was ist da los?
Doch funktioniert.
Ja, ich kann mich schon noch dran erinnern, WBPDD.
Aber kann ich dir leider nicht bei helfen.
Weil ich habe vorhin gesagt, du hast mit einem Notebook bestimmt.
Da kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Beste Wiederbelebung ever.
Jetzt erstmal wieder umgewöhnen von diesem Call of Duty Zeug zu einem ordentlichen Game.
Ich hab Hunger, muss was fressen.
Ich dachte, du wärst cool und kennst dich damit aus.
Ja leider ist es durch Handauflegen nicht getan.
Da kann man in V-Mode halt nichts machen.
Jetzt Blitz.
Der lebt noch, ne?
Ah ne, der ist down.
Ich dachte, der lebt noch.
Ja, WBPD, was willst du denn, dass ich mache?
Ich kann von hier an deinem Notebook nichts machen.
Ich hab dir vorhin meine Meinung dazu schon gesagt, woran ich denke, dass es liegt.
Jetzt hast du gesagt, du hast Notebook?
Okay, aber was soll ich denn machen?
Alter.
Also im Notebook kannst du wahrscheinlich eh nicht viel dran machen, wenn das kaputt ist.
Du kommst ja an die Teile nicht dran.
Sollst erst mal wieder in das Game reinkommen.
Schon genug von Cort, ja, reicht.
Game ist immer wieder gecrashed die ganze Zeit.
Was heißt immer wieder die ganze Zeit?
Das war ja quasi permanent gecrashed.
Das war einziger Crash.
Hier ist super Position.
Kann man das alle own.
Hoffentlich wird der Server jetzt ein bisschen voller, wenn wir im Server-Programm ein bisschen steigen wegen Player Count.
Das Game ruckelt?
Habt ihr das gesehen?
Hat geruckelt.
Battlefield 3 ruckelt ein.
Fuck, das war nochmal ein Granatwerf.
Wer will hier rumliegen?
Wer hat gerade alle M-Coms gelegt?
Ah, fuck.
Ich dachte, er ist weg.
Aber wie einfach alle M-Coms hochgehen in der Zwischenzeit.
Du musst aufpassen, dass die uns nicht schrecken.
Und vorne.
Okay, wo ist hier was?
Du kannst nicht an einer Ecke stehen, das stimmt.
Mal gucken, ob das Timing passt.
Komm, komm, geh auf Map.
Fuck.
Nein.
Das war echt eine Sekunde zu früh.
Das ruckelt?
Das Game ruckelt?
Battlefield 3 ruckelt nie.
Battlefield kann gar nicht ruckeln.
Boom.
Ich hab Hunger.
Ich muss mal gleich was zu Essen holen.
Die werden jetzt geschreckt da drüben.
Der Hans.
Jetzt aber. Jetzt müsste das klappen.
Vielleicht soll ich mal ein PC neu starten, wenn sogar Battlefield ruckelt.
Vielleicht hat das neue Call of Duty einfach komplett PC gereckt, zerstört.
Quasi, wenn man einmal eingeloggt war und Call of Duty gespielt hat, dann muss man PC neu starten, dass es wieder rausgeht.
Nach gestern war wieder alles okay.
Ernsthaft jetzt? Das wäre aber ganz schöner Fail.
Das ist ja schon fast Sabotage.
Moment, wir haben ne scheiß Parkauswahl.
Das wäre schon fast Sabotage dann.
Wenn wir das jetzt mal legen.
Das ruckelt? Ernsthaft? Das Game ruckelt?
Das Game ruckelt nie. Das kann nur am Call of Duty liegen.
Aber das Server wird jetzt langsam voll.
Das ist gut. Wir können auch noch ein paar ordentliche Runden spielen.
Ich minimiere mal alles im Hintergrund.
Bringt das ja was.
Go, go. So ordentliche Runden haben.
Sebaro, wolltest du nicht mitspielen?
Hallo Tommy.
Max, hast du schon mal mit HTML und CSS programmiert?
Wobei es da jetzt wieder Klugscheißer gibt, die sagen, dass man mit HTML und CSS nicht programmieren kann.
Aber das sehe ich nicht so schlimm.
Das sehe ich nicht so eng.
Ich finde man kann das als programmieren bezeichnen.
Ich sag's doch. Wir haben ja schon zwei Kandidaten im Chat gerade wieder.
Was ist dir meine Meinung zur COD, Peter? Macht Spaß, aber jedes neue COD macht Spaß.
PC Port ist scheiße.
Einfach scheiße.
Und meine Position ist auch scheiße.
Es kann nicht sein, dass Battlefield rockelt.
Nur weil ich Call of Duty gespielt habe auf dem Rechner.
Bis ich neu starte.
Hallo? What the fuck?
Ich wusste das erst.
Ich muss aufpassen, dass ich von der anderen Seite geoutet werde.
Das ist so typisch im Battlefield.
Einfach mal sinnlos... Oh fuck, ich hab keine Munition mehr.
Haben wir noch Munition, Leute? Irgendwo hier?
M16, jawoll.
Jetzt wird's OP.
Und Smoke.
Eigentlich sollten wir nicht rauspushen. Ist keine gute Idee.
Die gehen jetzt zu A. Ich wette mit euch, die gehen zu B. Ich wusste das.
Gehen wir mal rüber.
Ich defuse weiter.
Durchgedrückt.
Ich kriege noch ein Rätsel.
Wo sind wir?
OP Waffe.
Server wird langsam voll.
Ich bleib hier mal bei A, auf der Seite.
Da kann man nämlich auch wunderbar rüber in Gang ballern.
Ich geh mal rüber.
Ich geh mal auf die andere Seite gucken.
So wie ich die kenne, sind sie nämlich clever.
Ich dachte mir schon, dass ihr hier rüber kommt. Nein.
Da ist er.
Das war ein Trick 17.
Da hat er mitgedacht.
Wie viele, wie viele.
Cheap baited, aber Elmo richtig cheap baited war das.
Mega cheap baited.
Habe ich nicht gesehen.
Dies habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ganz ganz wichtig, dass ich das enable.
Ja ja scheiße.
Wenn wir hier OP Position einnehmen.
Game, lass mich doch da hoch klettern.
Warum rennt ihr raus? Lasst doch hier Defenden.
Warum geht ihr raus? Hier drin ist doch viel einfacher.
Komm rein.
Komm her.
Oh fuck, mit der Shotgun.
So macht man das. Das Ding ist auch wirklich schwer.
Ich glaube, ich kann hier länger spielen. Ich muss jetzt was futtern.
Ich habe so übertrieben Hunger.
Aber ich musste jetzt was spielen. Ich musste noch nach dieser Call of Duty PC Port Kacke.
Ich muss jetzt noch eine Runde Battlefield spielen.
Ich hatte eigentlich nicht vor, am Rechner zu essen.
Unsere Perks sind übrigens kacke Leute.
Camp. Ja, ein bisschen Camp gehört dazu.
Kann man da schon einen Panzer hören? Ja, ich höre da einen Panzer.
Ich höre da einen Panzer.
Komm her, komm her.
Da steht jetzt der andere um die Ecke und wartet, dass ich rauspushe.
Doch nicht. Hätte ich jetzt gedacht.
Abstand von der Wand halten.
Ich muss mal gucken, dass hier nichts über den Langmittelgang kommt.
Wenn der Panzer kaputt.
Der Panzer lebt immer noch.
Das war ganz schön der Panzer. Ich muss spawnen.
Unbedingt hier engineer irgendwas, was den Panzer kaputt machen kann.
Die Panzer nicht kaputt kriegen.
Nicht B alleine lassen, Leute. Nicht B alleine lassen.
Panzer, Panzer.
Ich habe Hunger.
Das Spiel ruckelt.
Nie.
Du kannst immer voll vergessen.
Ich meine, wo steht da eigentlich ein Panzer?
Scheiß auf den Panzer.
Wir können nicht auf den Panzer scheißen.
Wir müssen mal mitte gucken.
Fuck.
Der Typ weiß schon mal, wie man Panzer fährt.
Der ist hinter den Steinen.
Wir müssen mal umswitchen auf was ordentliches wieder.
Da kommt wieder ein Panzer.
Fast gegen den Panzer.
Flankerino.
Das ist ein neuer Scott.
Der PC-Port ist abgefuckt.
Das ist ein bisschen scheiße.
Warum hat er sich nicht wieder vernäht?
Es gibt bestimmt genug, bei denen es gut läuft, aber bei mir nachweislich nicht.
Ich muss sagen, es sackt bei mir.
Die Grafik ist schlechter als Battlefield.
Es läuft schlecht.
Vor allem läuft es schlecht.
Jetzt aber.
Das ist ein geiler Flank.
Das Spiel sieht nicht gut aus.
Ich habe es schon auf mittel oder niedrig gestellt.
Vor allem, wenn man sich die Handschuhe angeguckt hat.
Wir haben den Panzer geklaut.
Steig ein.
Das ist ein guter Panzer.
Da oben ist er.